Im Jahr 1971 kam in Pretoria, Südafrika unweit
von Johannesburg, Elon Musk als erster Sohn
von Errol und Maye Musk zur Welt.
Es wurde schnell klar, dass der Junge etwas
Besonderes war.
So verfiel er oft in regelrechte Trance-Zustände,
in denen man ihn einfach nicht ansprechen
konnte.
Außerdem war er sehr logik-orientiert und
versuchte so beim Spielen einem seiner Freunde,
der sich im Dunklen fürchtete zu erklären,
dass Dunkelheit nur die Abwesenheit von Licht
sei.
Es war nicht selten für den Jungen bis zu
zehn Stunden am Tag zu lesen, eine Gewohnheit
die ihm schnell zu einer intellektuellen Überlegenheit
gegenüber seinen altersgleichen Mitmenschen
verhalf, weshalb Musk immer etwas isoliert
und einsam war und auch immer wieder Opfer
von Mobbing wurde.
Musk wuchs nach der Scheidung seiner Eltern
1981 vor allem bei seinem Vater auf, bei dem
er zum einen sehr viele Privilegien genoss,
aber zum anderen auch eine sehr schwere Kindheit
hatte.
So wurde sowohl Musk als auch sein Bruder
Kimbal einer Art psychologischen Folter ausgesetzt,
über die beide bis heute nicht genauer sprechen.
Er sagte in einem Interview über seine Kindheit
"I had a terrible upbringing.
I had a lot of adversity growing up.
One thing I worry about with my kids is they
don't face enough adversity“
Auch der Unternehmer in Musk kam schnell zum
Vorschein, als er bspw.
im Alter von 12 Jahren ein innovatives Computerspiel
namens Blastar auf den Markt brachte und damit
an die 500 Dollar verdiente als er den Code
an ein PC Spiel Magazin verkaufte.
Auch eröffneten er und seine Cousins einmal
eine Videospielhalle ohne das Wissen oder
der Genehmigung der Eltern.
Mit 17 Jahren „floh“ er aus Südafrika
nach Canada, um nicht den Militärdienst antreten
zu müssen.
Dort studierte er zunächst an der Queens-Universität,
später in Pennsylvania und landete schlussendlich
an der Wharton School, wo er sowohl den Bachlelor
of Physics als auch Economics erwarb.
Während seiner Zeit in Pennsylvania vermietete
er ein Bruderschafts-Haus als Nightclub, um
seine College-Gebühren zu zahlen.
Doch das war für ihn pures Business, während
die anderen Party machten, spielte er oft
allein Videospiele.
Sein erstes wirkliches Unternehmen namens
Zip2 gründete er im Jahr 1995 gemeinsam mit
seinem Bruder und etwa 28.000 $ Startkapital
von seinem Vater.
Mit diesem halfen sie Zeitungsverlagen, Online-City
Guides zu erstellen.
Das Unternehmen wurde 1999 für 307 Millionen
$ an Compaq verkauft und Musk verdiente bei
dem Verkauf von Zip2 an die 22 Millionen US-Dollar.
Ein Monat nach dem Verkauf gründete Elon
X-Com eines der Unternehmen welches im Jahr
2001 gemeinsam mit Peter Thiels Confinity
zu Pay-Pal verschmelzen sollte.
2002 wurde Pay-Pal für 1.5 Milliarden an
Ebay verkauft, Elon Musk war wieder um 165
Millionen reicher.
Mit dem neu gewonnenen Vermögen blieb Musk
nicht lange inaktiv und gründete 2002 SpaceX,
das wohl erfolgreichste private Raumfahrtunternehmen
aller Zeiten.
2004 stieg er schließlich in den Elektroautohersteller
Tesla ein und übernahm im Jahr 2008 während
der Wirtschaftskrise die volle Kontrolle über
das Unternehmen und wurde CEO.
Auch Solar-City, Hyperloop oder OpenAI sind
einige der weiteren Projekte von Musk.
Er lebt geschieden hat aber mit der Schriftstellerin
Justine Musk insgesamt 5 Kinder, einmal Zwillinge
und einmal Drillinge.
Sein Vermögen wird aktuell auf etwa 20 Milliarden
Dollar taxiert.
Philosophie
Elon Musk ist offensichtlicherweise kein traditioneller
Börseninvestor sondern jemand, der in jedem
seiner Investments aktiv mitwirkt, zu sehr
hohem Risiko bereit ist und dafür auch mit
Renditen jenseits derer die an der Börse
zu erzielen sind, belohnt wurde.
Doch können wir als langfristig orientierte
Investoren dann überhaupt etwas von Elon
Musk lernen?
Die Antwort lautet ja!
Man kann nämlich immer von den Leuten lernen,
welche in der Welt in der man selbst etwas
erreichen will, zu der Spitze zählen.
Nachdem Elon Musk in die USA auswanderte,
identifizierte er in seiner Universitätszeit
vor allem drei Bereiche in denen er zukünftig
noch viel Potential sah.
Zu diesen Bereichen zählten die Weltallerforschung,
erneuerbare Energien und das Internet.
Damals war ihm zwar klar, dass diese Bereiche
die Welt verändern würden, in welcher Weise
er aber in ihnen aktiv werden würde, wusste
er nicht.
Er wollte nach eigenen Angaben nie Unternehmer
werden, doch es war schlussendlich einfach
die beste Möglichkeit um seine Träume und
Ziele zu verwirklichen.
Auf die Frage, wieso er auch nach seinem Reichtum
durch Pay-Pal noch weitere Projekte startete
und sich mit Tesla und SpaceX mehrmals einem
starken Insolvenzrisiko aussetzte antwortet
er nur: Wenn ich an die Zukunft denke, soll
es spannend sein und nicht langweilig.
Musk selbst verfolgt bei seinen Investitionen
also nie primär monetäre Aspekte, da er
aber im Grunde immer in Bereiche mit enormen
Potentialen investiert und zwar immer nur
mit dem Ansatz die Monopolstellung in dem
jeweiligen Bereich zu übernehmen, sind hohe
Renditen oft ein netter Nebeneffekt.
So hat er mit SpaceX eine ganz klare Monopolstellung
im Markt der privaten Raumfahrtunternehmen
und ist auch mit Tesla der einzige Autokonzern,
welcher sich bisher ausschließlich auf Elektromobilität
fokussiert.
Jedoch hat er dort immer wieder mit massiven
Problemen zu kämpfen, wie aktuell dem Model
3, welches viele technische Mängel haben
soll.
Musks Ideen und Lebensansichten
Frei nach dem Motto, wenn du nach den Sternen
schießt und scheiterst landest du immer noch
auf dem Mars ist Elon Musk ein Mann großer
Ziele und Visionen.
Anstatt also zu sagen, dass er mit seinem
Raumfahrunternehmen SpaceX zwei große Fracht-Raketen
auf den Mars schicken will um Wasser-Ressourcen
zu entdecken und erste Infrastruktur aufzubauen.
Um danach zwei weitere Raketen mit Besatzung
auf den Mars zu schicken, welche die Grundlage
für eine Kolonialisierung des Planeten ist,
sagt Musk, dass er bis 2022 2 Frachtraketen
und bis 2024 2 weitere Raketen mit Besatzung
auf dem Mars haben will.
Gibt also extrem ambitionierte Fristen für
seine Ziele vor.
Und auch wenn er mit seinen Zeitplänen oft
um Jahre zu früh dran ist, so schafft er
doch immer wieder Dinge, die man zuvor für
unmöglich hielt möglich zu machen.
Wie er das schafft?
Nicht nur durch die reine Kraft des Kapitalismus.
Einerseits investiert Musk die Erlöse aus
früheren Exits konsequent in größere und
ambitioniertere Unternehmen, andererseits
setzt er auch auf Staatsunterstützung.
Laut Recherche der Times, hat er vor allem
für Tesla Motors, Solar City und Spaceex
insgesamt etwa 4,9 Milliarden $ an Subventionen
von der US Regierung erhalten.
Als Beispiel für sein ambitioniertestes Projekt
ist nichts geringeres als SpaceX zu nennen
welches bis heute neben Blue Origin das einzige
private Unternehmen weltweit ist, welches
Raketen auf der Erde landen lies und es nur
kurze Zeit später wieder in das Weltall zurückschickte.
Im September 2017 stellte er seine neuesten
Mars-Pläne vor, bei der er eine vollständige
Kolonialisierung des Planeten bis zum Jahr
2100 vorsieht.
SpaceX entwickelt für dieses gigantische
Projekt aktuell die Big fucking rocket Rakete,
welche zu den größten Raketen gehört, die
jemals vom Menschen gebaut worden sind.
Bei seinen Unternehmen beschäftigt er sich
neben seiner Führungstätigkeit hauptsächlich
mit Design und dem Ingenieurswesen und das
obwohl Musk nichts von beiden studiert hat.
Er studierte nämlich Physik und Wirtschaft,
wobei vor allem das Physikstudium die Grundlage
für viele seiner Projekte bildet.
Grundsätzlich betrachtet er alle Probleme
zuerst mit den einfachsten Grundlagen der
Physik und nicht danach, wie andere Unternehmen
oder Menschen diese Probleme angehen.
Mit diesem Ansatz ist er enorm innovativ,
da er immer alles von Grund auf neu entwickelt
und dabei viele sinnlose Dinge die sich in
der jeweiligen Industrie eingebürgert haben
einfach ignoriert.
So hat er beispielsweise in der Autoindustrie
viele bis dahin bekannte Weisheiten einfach
ignoriert und damit bewiesen, dass diese scheinbaren
Weisheiten einfach nur alteingebürgerte Dummheiten
sind.
Gleiches gilt für SpaceX oder auch für die
Boring Company eine seiner neueren Unternehmungen.
Dabei handelt es sich um ein Unternehmen dessen
Ziel es ist Tunnelsysteme unter Städten zu
graben.
Die Autos werden über in die Straße eingebaute
Lifte in den Untergrund befördert und auf
Schienen gestellt, auf welchen sie mit Geschwindigkeiten
von bis zu 200 km/h fahren können.
Damit würde man sich enorm viel Stau sparen
und wenn man es richtig umsetzt, muss das
Ganze nicht einmal wahnsinnig teuer sein.
Um auf so eine Idee zu kommen muss man alle
Konventionen ignorieren und beginnen ganz
neu zu denken.
Die Boring Company ist aktuell übrigens daran
neben einer Tesla Fabrik einen Tunnel zu graben
und hat bereits erste Testfahrten der Schienen
in diesen Tunneln durchgeführt.
Aufgrund seiner hohen Intelligenz gilt Musk
wie viele andere sehr erfolgreiche Persönlichkeiten
auch als eine eher unverträgliche Person
mit geringer Empathie-Fähigkeit und Verständnis
für geringeren Intellekt.
Auf der anderen Seite ist er aber laut Aussage
vieler seiner Freunde und vertrauten Mitarbeitern
einer der Menschen mit denen man die faszinierendsten
Gespräche führen kann, auf der anderen Seite
ist er auch ein knallharter Chef, dessen Härte
viele Mitarbeiter nicht lange aushalten.
So feuerte er z.b.
seine persönliche Assistentin nach Jahrelanger
Arbeit kurzerhand, als er nach einem kurzen
Krankenstand ihrerseits bemerkte, dass er
die Arbeit auch ohne sie erledigt bekam
Elon Musk ist außerdem mit einer herausragenden
Lernfähigkeit ausgestattet und versteht vor
allem technische Prozesse auf Anhieb, was
ihm auch ermöglicht zwei derartig hochkomplexe
technologische Konzerne wie SpaceX und Tesla
aus Sicht des Ingenieurwesens zu leiten ohne
jemals Ingenieurswesen studiert zu haben.
Fazit
Alles in allem verkörpert Elon Musk einige
der wichtigsten Aspekte, wenn es darum geht
als Investor oder auch Unternehmer erfolgreich
zu werden.
Ob es nun darum geht immer neugierig zu bleiben,
gegen den Strom zu schwimmen oder auch einmal
die Bereitschaft zu haben Risiken einzugehen,
all das sind Eigenschaften die man sich von
Elon Musk abschauen kann und sollte.
Schlussendlich fasst folgendes Zitat von Elon
seine Denkweise recht gut zusammen:
Als ich ein Kind war, habe ich mich gefragt,
was der Sinn des Lebens ist und ich habe verstanden,
dass es darum geht die richtigen Fragen zu
stellen.
Und ich habe realisiert, dass wir für eine
gute Zukunft sicherstellen müssen, dass wir
nachhaltig wirtschaften und mit nachhaltigen
Energien arbeiten.
Auch halte ich es für unfassbar wichtig,
dass wir eine multiplanetare Spezies werden.
Und zwar nicht nur um die Menschheit so wie
wir sie kennen zu retten.
Das wichtigste für mich ist nämlich, dass
wir mit solchen Zielen ein Abenteuer erschaffen
und es schaffen, dass sich Leute für die
Zukunft begeistern und wenn Leute sich für
die Zukunft begeistern, gibt es Frieden, es
gibt Zusammenarbeit und es gibt kollektives
Glück in der Menschheit.
Es muss Gründe geben um aufzustehen und wenn
ich weiß, dass ich eines Tages durch die
Galaxie fliegen kann, stehe ich eher auf,
als wenn ich mein Leben lang auf der Erde
gefangen bin.
Ich persönlich bin bei Musk Zwiegestalten.
Einerseits liebe ich seinen unternehmerischen
Esprit und seine Ambitionen, ich finde es
allein deshalb wichtig, den Mars und den Mond
zu „erobern“ weil es verdammt cool ist.
Andererseits war ich sehr lange skeptisch
auch als ich seine Biographie gelesen habe,
weil ich den Eindruck hatte, dass er vieles
niemals erreichen wird, was er sich vornimmt.
Dann habe ich aber bei Bloomberg gesehen,
dass er tatsächlich sehr viele Ziele, sogar
mehr als die Hälfte der Ziele erreicht, wenn
auch verspätet.
Diese gewaltige Leistung ist einfach unfassbar
und sollte von jedem Menschen dieser Welt
anerkannt werden, allerdings ist es etwas
vollkommen anderes, sich daran als Investor
zu beteiligen, da jede einzelne Firma eine
Vielzahl von existentiellen Risiken birgt,
die wohl für einen gewöhnlichen Privatanleger
nur schwer zu bewerten sind.
Ich wünsche ihm und seinen Aktionären jedenfalls
allen Erfolg der Welt!